hello it's great to have so many people
who care about improving education come
together for this important forum I want
to acknowledge His Highness Sheikh
Mohammed bin Rashid for his commitment
to education and innovation in the
United Arab Emirates and around the
world the Gates Foundation is proud to
partner with His Highness
Dubai's care organization and with
others across the Gulf we're making
critical strides in education health and
development like all of you our
foundation believes in the power of
teachers to transform students lives
we're focused on ensuring that every
classroom has an effective well
supported teacher and on empowering
teachers to shape and build their
profession technology has a important
role to play in these efforts we're
bringing technology designers and
teachers together giving teachers the
opportunity to co.design the innovations
that they'll use in the classroom
keeping teachers at the center is a key
to finding the next breakthrough that's
why we were so excited about the plans
to launch the global teacher prize I
want to congratulate all 10 finalists
for their inspiring work I also want to
recognize the leadership of sunny Varkey
founder of gems education who had the
idea for this prize and is a great
partner for our foundation I hope that
each of you leaves the forum inspired
and motivated to keep innovating thank
you for being here